a couple of proud parents in the  building that's tina ball and lavar ball  that are the parents of both lamelo and  lonzo of course lonzo not playing he's  out with a knee but clearly proud of  what going on with lamela  a couple of proud parents in the  building that's tina ball and lavar ball  that are the parents of both lamello and  lonzo of course lonzo not playing he's  out with a knee but clearly proud of  what going on with lamela a couple of  proud parents in the building that's  tina ball and lavar ball that are the  parents of both lamelo and lonzo of  course lonzo not playing he's out with a  knee but clearly proud of what going on  with lamela